[موسيقى]
عنه 20 22 سيظل على ذاكره قطاع الطاقه
لاجيال المقبله نظرا للتحولات التاريخيه
التي بدات او تسارعت خلاله واضطرار الدول
الكبرى لاعاده رسم استراتيجيتها الطاقه
خلاله الحدث الاهم الذي حرك سلسله من
التطورات بعده كان اندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا ونجوب ازمه الغاز الاوروبيه
والتي ادت الى ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه بشكل
كبير واضطر العديد من الدول الى العوده
لاشكال الطاقه التقليديه ومنها الفحم الذي
سجل مستويات استهلاك قياسيه بحسب تقديرات
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
سنستعرض الان 4 ملفات اساسيه يجب ان
نتابعها ونراقبها في 20 23 يعني نبدا من
قطاع النفط حيث ان الاسعار تقلبت بشكل
كبير خلال عام 2022 في نطاق يزيد عن 50$
وكانت اوبيك كلاس هي العامل الذي خفف من
هذا التقلب من خلال زياده الانتاج بوتيره
متسارعه في الربعين الثاني والثالث ثم
العوده الى خفض الانتاج في الربع الاخير
بالنظر الى 20 23 يتنازعوا في السوق
عاملان اساسيان لابد ان نراقبهما مخاوف
الركود الذي قد يخفف الطلب العالمي من جهه
واحتمال ان يصل السوق الى محدوديه المعروض
في نهايه 20 23 من جهه اخرى وسواء اعتمدنا
توقعاتك او وكاله الطاقه الدوليه كلت
الجهتين تتوقعان ارتفاع الطلب على النفط
الى مستوى قياسي جديد في 20 23
اوبك تتوقع ان يصل الطلب الى 103 ملايين
و400,000 برميل يوميا في الربع الاخير من
العامل ارتفاعا من 99 مليون و600 الف
برميل يوميا في الربع الاخير من هذا العام
بمعدل 100 ومليون و700,000 برميل لسه
باكملها بينما تتوقع وكاله الطاقه ان
يتجاوز
103 ملايين برميل يوميا في الربع الاخير
من العام القادم وان يصل الطلب الى
101 او 100 مليون و600 الف برميل يوميا
كمعدل للسنه القادمه
والسؤال يبقى هل سيكون هناك ما يكفي من
المعروض لتلبيه هذا الطلب نهايه عام 20 23
وفي السنوات التاليه
السؤال يرتبط بالنقطه القادمه وهي
الاستثمارات في الطاقه فعلي الرغم من
تسارع الاستثمارات في الطاقات المتجدده
الا انها لا تبدو كافيه لسد فجوه الطلب
مجموعه بي سي جي للاستشارات تقدر الفجوه ب
22 تريليون دولار بين الانفاق الحالي على
الاستثمارات الطاقه وما يحتاجه العالم حتى
20 30 وبالتالي فان التوقعات تشير الى ان
العالم سيواجه المزيد من ازمات الطاقه اذا
لم يتم ضخ المزيد من الاستثمارات في مختلف
قطاعات الطاقه بما فيها النفط والغاز
يقودنا ذلك الى الحديث عن الطاقه المتجدده
وما اذا كانت قادره على سد الفجوه بلا شك
كان عام 20 22 مفصليا على هذا الصعيد
الاستثمارات تدفقت بوتيره اكبر على الواح
الشمسيه والبطاريات وتربينات الرياح
والاهم كان اقرار قانون خفض التضخم في
الولايات المتحده الذي رصد 369 مليار
دولار للطاقه المتجدده لكن يرى البعض ان
هذه الاستثمارات بالرغم من ذلك غير كافيه
للدفع بالطاقه المتجدده بالسرعه المطلوبه
لتلبيه الطلبه العالمي على الطاقه اخيرا
لابد ان نتحدث عن اوروبا التي بدات
بالتخلي عن رفضها للعقود طويله الاجل
الاستيراد الغاز وراينا كيف وقعت المانيا
عقدا لاستيراد الغاز المسال من قطر لمده
15 سنه في 20 23 سيكون التحدي الاكبر امام
اوروبا اعاده ملئ خزانات الغاز بعد فصل
الشتاء الحالي لتفادي الوقوع في عجز
الشتاء المقبل وهو ما تحذر منه وكاله
الطاقه الدوليه
سنراقب ايضا في 20 23 اذا كيف سيتطور
التعامل مع امدادات الطاقه الروسيه وهل
سيكون هناك تشدد في تطبيق السقف السعري
على الغاز في اوروبا والسقف السعري على
النفط الروسي الى اي حد ستنخفض الامدادات
الروسيه بسبب هذين السقفين وكيف سيصبح
مزيج الطاقه الاوروبي نتيجه لذلك
[موسيقى]
اذا اضطرابات حاده شهدها قطاع الطاقه هذا
العام فماذا يحمل عام 20 23 ابرز تلك
الملفات ناقشناها مع الكاتب وخبير الطاقه
العالمي دانيال اليوروغان في مقابله خاصه
مع مستقبل الطاقه بداناها بسؤاله هل ازمه
الطاقه في 20 22 عطلت عمليه التحول ام
ستكون محفزا للسياسات والاستثمارات
المطلوبه لتقديم الحلول الضروريه لخلق
طاقه موثوقه ومستدامه وذا التكلفه معقوله
[موسيقى]
سبورت 2016
اذا هل نستطيع ان نجزم بان عام 20 23
سيشهد
استمرارالشح الامدادات والتقلبات السعريه
الحاده التي عشناها هذا العام الدراسي
الاتحاد الاوروبي ينفق مليارات الدولار
اليوم على عقود طويله الاجل لتوريد الغاز
وعلى تشييد بنيه تحتيه جديده مثل محطات
استقبال الغاز المسال وانابيب غاز فرعيه
لكن في الوقت ذاته يطالب الاتحاد الاوروبي
افريقيا تحديدا بعدم استخدام مواردها
الطبيعيه الاحفوريه في خطتها التنمويه
اليس هذا مثال صارخ على ازدواجيه المعايير
في رايك
كويس جدا
[موسيقى]
العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه انهت العام
على نبره اقل سلبيا مما بدانا العام عليه
في ظل الاجتماع الذي جمع الرئيس سان بيدن
وشيجن بيج وجها لوجه على هامش قمه الجي 20
قمه 20 الاخيره هل من الممكن ان يغير هذا
من اثار المنافسه الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
الصينيه على منظومه الطاقه العالميه
عايزك تقيسي طيب خلاص
شكرا شكرا
شهدت هذه السنه ظهورا قويا للهيدروجين
النظيف في دوائر صنع القرار ان كان في
الخطط الاستراتيجيه للطاقه في الولايات
المتحده الاير ايه او في الاتحاد الاوروبي
همم
هل تعتقد بان التطورات الاخيره همم تضع
الهيدروجين النظيف على سكه تحقيقه لما
يراه البعض بانها قدرات كبيره كامله في
هذا الوقود
يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع فاصل قصير متابع بعده
دانيال يورجن يتوقعوا انتهاء حقبه سوق
النفط العالميه الحره وتحولها الى سوق
مكسر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نعود مشاهدينا الى
متابعه المقابله الخاصه مع الكاتب وخبير
الطاقه العالمي دانيال
في الجزء الثاني من المقابله الى مناقشه
تطورات السوق النفطيه من كافه جوانبها
فيما يخص الملف الجيو السياسي والعقوبات
الغربيه غير المسبوقه على روسيا حيث اكد
يورجن ان تكون العقوبات التي تستهدف
المشتقات النفطيه الروسيه
القادمه هي الامتحان الحقيقي
العالميه الحره وتحولها الى سوق مكسره
فيديو منى
[موسيقى]
همم ادي ايس كاب
بيوتي
العقوبات التي تستهدف الطاقه هي سلاح تم
استخدامه بشكل غير مسبوق هذا العام ما هي
اثار ذلك على التدفقات التجاريه للسوق
النفطيه وجهاتها وهل نشهد اليوم اعاده رسم
لخارطه الطاقه العالميه وهل احدى المخرجات
هي السوق نفطيه مجزئه ومتشضيه يعني
اول مره
[موسيقى]
اكيد مش كويسه
دعنا اذا نتحدث دكتور عن سوق النفط اليوم
شهدت اسعار النفط انخفاض الحاده خلال
الاشهر القليله الاخيره بقياده المخاوف من
الركود الاقتصاد العالمي وتشدد الفيدرالي
لكن العقوبات على روسيا وتخارج الصين من
سياسه صفر كوفد قد يحرك الاسعار صعودا كيف
ترى حركه السوق النفطيه ونحن ندخل العام
الجديده
[موسيقى]
عالمي سعودي
سوري
الانتاج بواقع مليونير ميلا يوميا في
اكتوبر قد اثبت بانه قرار صائب بالرغم من
الاصوات العاليه التي وصفته بغير ذلك في
حينها الاجتماع المقبل للتحالف سيكون في
يوليو القادم في نظرتك المستقبليه للسوق
النفطيه هل تتوقع بان تقوم المجموعه بخفض
اضافي في موعد اقرب
[موسيقى]
من اسكندريه
على خلفيه العقوبات وتغير التدفقات
التجاريه في السوق النفطيه في اي مرحله
تصبح روسيا عبئا على اوبك بدلا من داعم
لهبكي
[موسيقى]
24 سنه
بعد خفض حاد في نوفمبر قامت اداره معلومات
الطاقه الامريكيه برفع توقعتها للانتاج
الامريكي النفطي للعام 20 23 الى نحو 12
مليون
و340,000 برميل يوميا لتتجاوز ان حدث ذلك
الانتاج القياسي عام 2019 والبالغ 12
مليون و320 الف برميل يوميا لكن برغم من
ذلك هل تتوقع ان نشهد تباطئ ملحوظا في نمو
انتاج النفط الصخري الامريكي
عايز
[موسيقى]
اثبتت وقائع وبيانات العرض والطلب في
السوق النفطيه خلال الاشهر القليله
الاخيره من عام 20 22 22
وذلك بالرغم من الاصوات العديده التي
تعادلت في حينها والتي اتهمت المجموعه
بتسيس القرار وشككت بمصداقيته وزير الطاقه
السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان اكد
في تصريح اخيرا على انه لولا النهج
الاشتباقي والخطوات الوقائيه التي
اعتمدتها او اعتمدها تحالف بلاست
هذه الصدمات فوضى كبيره في اسواق النفط
[موسيقى]
رياضه مشاهدينا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه
اخر حلقه مستقبل الطاقه لعام 20 22 للمزيد
دائما تابعونا على تويتر تحت اوسم هاشتاج
مستقبل الطاقه يمكنكم الاستماع الى
حلقاتنا على العربيه
[موسيقى]